heads up guys my name is a cha know how
would you like the opportunity to truly
be my student Google have launched this
new service called helpouts and it
seemed perfect however they don't accept
paypal as payment which is something
many of you require so I created my own
little help outs this allows me to teach
you face to face as if we were just
talking on skype I'd be able to teach
you programming in Java and C++ as well
as game development and programming
privately and directly I'll answer all
your questions give you homework and
make sure that you're actually on your
way to making your own games and
applications booking in 15 30 or 60
minute tutorial is really easy simply
visit the janitor calm fall / tutoring
which you'll find in the description
below and check out my calendar find a
time that's right for you but know that
the calendar is in australian eastern
time then fill out the form below with
your preferred time and details I'll get
back to you shortly to confirm your
booking and skype account it's as simple
as that you'll be able to go way beyond
the scope of my game programming
tutorials and learn programming straight
from me I look forward to teaching you